it is so wonderful to see both of you
because this
is a love letter to ireland and both of
you just are the sweetest characters
i mean jamie for you to take on anthony
is so refreshing
he's interesting he's oblivious doesn't
know how to deal with girls and
just so quirky what was it like for you
to take on his role
well i think i'm probably most of those
things you listed there
so um so i guess that was
a neat fit you know um listen it was
it was a a departure from anything i'd
done before you know and
and uh i i've been longing to
to play someone like that who isn't
maybe so
assured of themselves and so in control
because i am definitely not myself
so you know it was refreshing for me and
a cool opportunity to show a different
side of myself i guess and offer up a
different character than maybe what
people are used to seeing from me so
yeah i had the time of my life making it
i loved it
yeah i loved it it really fits you i
think it's just
natural for you to take on a roll like
this thank you
and m emily is the fact is you made
christopher walken cry
like those tears that performance i mean
that's a moment
i was i was in awe of that moment what
was it like for you did you go home and
tell john about it and
oh yeah i mean i i yes i did i
i was so moved by him you know because i
think
chris is is is such a gentle soul and i
think everyone does
these heightened impersonations of him i
think he must be one of the most
impersonated people in the world but
he's actually quite delicate and fragile
and sweet
and his emotions are right there and so
when i started to sing
and he started to cry it was one of
those
moments i will never forget i honestly
was like what's happening
you know because he's such an icon he's
so extraordinary it was really cool
it was such a beautiful moment it was so
nice to see and
and then there's the whole storyline
with the proposal to the donkey
and you know such it's a funny moment
but
it made me think about my own proposal
because when my husband proposed to me
18 years ago i was complaining about the
flies
and he was doing his thing and i missed
the whole damn thing
and i don't know what was happening and
he's like six two and he was up anyway
it was a disaster
but it made me think about what is the
most
memorable moment for you from your
proposal
oh gosh go on jamie
i mean just the the shock got a yes you
know yeah
um you're always just like
kind of prepared for just
rejection and it's sort of most
successful
you don't know you don't know there's no
guarantees in this in this game you know
um but you were also dressed as a donkey
which was sort of an extra challenge for
millie in that moment
i was i was and it was a sort of sign
for things to come
you know and uh one day don't get an
extra turtle you don't know what you're
gonna get with me really you know
and my wife seems to like that
[Laughter]
how can you top that
am i going to top that from your
proposal
i mean how can i compete with jamie's
animalistic qualities i just i don't
know if i can
oh i love you guys and uh happy holidays
to both of you congratulations on the
film thank you
thank you so much thank you so much